are you excited to go you guys excited
to go to england though because uh yeah
it's you it's gonna be your second time
in england right second first time
first one doesn't count so what do you
mean i was barely you barely saw
anything yeah you were there for like
how long like i don't even remember like
five days i think not even a week i
don't think it's like two good weather
spoons this time
yeah you took me to
arguably one of the shittiest was
probably the [ __ ] is weather spoons yeah
yeah
you still haven't taken me to the
[ __ ] uh like you haven't still you
haven't given me like a tesco meal deal
or anything we'll do that too i thought
maybe should i do like a tearless video
i don't probably shouldn't say that on
camera because then people will now
expect it like a
meal deal dear list
like the optimum thing because someone
like i i we spoke about it wait did we
speak about it on the episode no no we
did not shawn but i [ __ ] i won't speak
about it uh
[ __ ] what am i going to say now then
new deal tier list
i'll do a meal deal how many meal deals
are there combinations are endless jay
really endless damn
there's there's quite a lot actually
depending on which stores you go to
different things so yeah it's really
yeah
is that is that what the wedding
dance like my wedding my wedding i'm
like yo the meal deal combination
let me just let me show you about that
it's gonna be a dance
everyone else is going to get like a
nice fancy like five
meals
and on connor's death we're just gonna
give him a meal
there
no i'm excited though because like you
know greg's as well you've
pasties oh the pasties places yeah yeah
yeah i gotta i gotta try this i gotta
try these pasties well i mean like you
know because we're probably gonna be
there
a little longer now like at least like a
week or a bit yeah so like i'm planning
hopefully for like conor to take me to
wales
yeah we'll see if we can do that we'll
see if we can do that do that i told my
parents i was like yeah maybe maybe i'll
see you maybe maybe
we'll see yeah well it's fun because
otherwise um
let's be real i'm never going to go to
wales otherwise
it'll be the only chance right exactly
amazing hiking yes yeah yeah because uh
you guys are gonna be there and a lot of
other people are gonna be flying in as
well so it's gonna be like really
busy i guess two the days leading up and
uh even the days that you fly in yeah
honestly i'm hyped though yeah i'm high
yeah good it's gonna be like way more
packs than your last trip to england i
think because i can't why did you come
to your last trip i can't remember
because we kazaki and i were already in
europe oh that's because we went to
cotton finland and we would we were just
like let's just go on a europe tour yeah
and then yeah the last stop was the uk
because we were like yeah i've never
i've never been to the uk
weirdly even though i have like a lot of
me to live there yeah it was good though
brighton was cool
we'll have we'll have uh we're having a
lad site last night out there yeah yeah
cause kevin's been like [ __ ]
messaging me every day about how keen he
is for a lads night and i'm just like
okay okay he's always keen he's always
keen
kevin when aren't you keen for a last
night let's be honest kevin
we are like i mean did you get to see a
lot of london last time because i don't
know what really looks like some
brighton most of the time yeah you're in
brighton most of the time and i don't
know if you showed him any of london
that's all
london's hard to you took us to uh like
a bunch of like the oh i mean you
because like aki's parents were there as
well right yeah so you kind of like took
us to like all of the you know the
touristy places i guess luckily london
is really convenient for tourist stuff
where they like put everything really
close together yeah yeah so you can
smash it all out on a day yeah right i
don't know with london it's kind of hard
if you don't drink the only place i
remember was you took us to like the
harry potter place oh yeah kings cross
whatever it is yeah the platform nine
through course yeah yeah yeah it's so
weird taking people to kings cross
because i just see it as like a train
station it is yeah and it is because
it's like i think how people imagine it
is just like going to the harry potter
land in like universal studios or
something right where you have [ __ ]
diagon alley they serve you like the you
know whatever like the beer is there the
butter beer whatever and it's not it's
just like one one like
one like half cut out train trolley and
uh a shop and then the rest of it is
just a [ __ ] normal station it's
pretty busy though it is really busy
yeah it's always been luckily they put
it out of the way of the station so if
you're gonna get a train you don't
actually go near it yeah but there's a
pub behind it that sometimes i don't
know why i've been to it but it's kind
of annoying to you know you're going to
give it
to me it's a harry potter thing
no it's just a normal park very normal
park yeah yeah
i do miss pubs actually i can't wait to
go to the pub again yeah that's all i've
been missing that's it really yeah i
will say england has definitely upped up
their bar game since since i've uh since
i've been away yeah there's a lot more
gaming bars and
themed bars as well
like uh anything's better than the
gaming bar you guys took me too yeah
yeah
uh when i was back last time and it was
good it's just again really expensive
yeah really really expensive that's
that's the price you pay like i guess
like literally that's the price you pay
for like the uh
water
for like the upscale of just you know
themed bars and everything like because
i know we've complained about it before
in trash taste and i remember this time
uh we also celebrated a birthday as well
and uh we uh
sydney's uh sydney's uh
maid of honor uh i say maid of honor
because her maid of honor is actually a
guy
um he booked he booked her this uh this
very weird like uh not not weird but it
was a themed bar where
uh it was basically like a cowboy themed
bar but it's not just like a theme bar
it was a whole like experience like it
feels it feels like i'm undermining it
just calling it a themed bar so you know
you go in and it's you know it's like
you just you know woke up in the south
it's you know southern america during
like the deep like when was like the
cowboy [ __ ] years i don't remember
1800s
[Music]
it's basically westport everyone's
talking in the southern accent and like
they have this you you get part you you
basically it's like bring your own booze
right and what they do is they they take
your booze whatever you choose to bring
and then they will make
whatever drinks well
is suitable with all of the booze that
you bring so you don't even buy
alcohol there you get served alcohol
there based on what you bring and you
get taken in and you know everyone's
like a cowboy and then and then suddenly
like a sheriff walks in and then this
whole there's this whole [ __ ]
storyline that's going on it's
it's like you know you get drunk yeah
yeah yeah they they serve you like
[ __ ] moonshine down like a back alley
and all this stuff and it's this it's
this entire experience entire storyline
that you get put into that it's
basically just a bar experience it
sounds like a universal studio's ride it
kind of is it kind of is which is they
serve you except with a lot of alcohol
oh my god i got like because because
because you bring your own booze there
and you know
there's no like
there's no like limit or there's no like
regulation for what you have to bring
there you mix a lot of [ __ ] drinks
so you end up getting very drunk and
then you wake up and you're just seeing
a bunch of [ __ ] cowboys like go at
each other and you're like where the
[ __ ] am i i'm in the middle of london
right now it's so [ __ ] weird i gotta
tell you guys that it just sounds like a
challenge like to like bring all your
own booze right and then it's just like
what if i guarantee there's been
instances where just someone just brings
in like bottles of just like nothing but
hard liquor yeah puts it on the thing
just like make it
trust vodka
what you gonna do
see there is like a lot more choice now
in terms of like just interesting bars
bars and bar experiences it's definitely
like leveled up
changing a lot it is changing brighton
is changing a lot as well like i i
i hardly even recognize the city i grew
up in anymore just because it's
it's become like this hip modern place
and like
it's gone to the point where you know
like you know you go to some american
bars and like or some bars abroad and
you just think yeah man every every bar
needs its thing you know
it's it's thing so i went to this like
re i was just like
perusing brighton and then there was
just this bar with a zipliner on it or
zipline on it i'm just like that's
that's the weirdest gimmick i've ever
seen but
[ __ ] i want to go on it man wait a zip
liner going out of the bar or a zipliner
going into the bar a zip line going out
of the bar so basically there is a bar
which just shows in the uk any gimmick
can work if there's a bar next to it
yeah so i think what happened right is
they built the zip line on like the sea
front and so there's a zip line so you
can climb up and you can zip line down
and you know it's like a dangerous
combination yeah yeah you can see the
beach and everything and then on the
bottom of the zip line there's just a
bar so it's just now the bar with the
zip line on it
people literally just zip line into the
seat of the bar just like
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
you start off in the bar and you can buy
tickets to go on the zip line and just
zip line down to like the opposite side
of like the beach or something like that
um and that's that's the bar that's
that's just the bar to be fair i would
probably go on that yeah yeah right i
would probably do that that's really fun
just shows like if
in the uk if you want to come up with
with a concept for a bar just come up
with a wacky concept doesn't matter what
a weird go-karts yeah with alcohol yeah
just put just just put this
just put some activity and alcohol and
british people will come to it yeah
that's yeah that's fairly accurate so
pretty spot on
yeah so
um so yeah i'm excited future comes back
uh i'm excited for you guys to come back
to london this time because there is a
lot more to do now so that's good i'm
sure we can plan out a lot more fun
things for you to do joey um i can't
remember what i showed you last time i
took you to oh i took you to devil's
dike which is oh yeah
which is still one of the most
questionably named places i've ever been
to
it's it's basically it's just a hill
it's just a hill it's a really nice hill
that's about it
i was just laughing the entire way when
i found out what it was called and i was
like they had they really didn't think
that english is a funny language yeah
english is a very funny language it was
a nice place yeah yeah
it's about it really that's about it i
can't i can't remember i can't remember
because you didn't stay in the uk for
that long no i don't remember i mean we
also uh
we also like drank at like brighton
beach and stuff like that but um
other than that that's about it